I just want to let all of you know that.
Shush.
Then started right stunning someone.
Only 70 I serve the transcript towards the end to all of you.
I mean a couple of times I tried.
It was amazing the way it created the meeting transcript was amazing.
I shared this towards the end of the call.
OK.
Yeah, yeah.
The copilot can also help in PowerPoint retrain, so we'll all have access to it training, OK.
Uh, we have a limited licenses.
OK.
If if you need a new A copilot license, please let your leaders know.
So that's now, they'll coordinate with me.
OK, OK, sure.
It's not free though it it doesn't come free with office it it's an additional license that we need to buy.
OK.
OK, session.
So quickly right now we have a slight modification to the existing leave policy here.
All know that we have different types of leaves that we have, right?
Previously and privileged Nashville mostly we have and we have only.
That is based on the tenure of a person and we have wedding leave for a person who's getting wedded and going.
And we also have maternity leave and all that.
So in this what we thought of doing is we anyways have this disconnect by majority of our clients at the end of the year and sometimes we are, you know not left with any big you know work also at the end of the year.
So we we actually spend idle time.
So instead we thought that we allocate maybe four days for that, which means we'll give like like option for today.
We have a bunch of list of holidays that we have out of that we choose right.
Similarly, we'll go with 6 + 4.
Six would be the privilege leave and the four will be allocated for this one.
So what happens is that six we have the choice to look at whichever days that we want to choose.
In this four, we have six days options that will be given two days in November and another four days in December.
Out of the six days we could choose any of the four days and we could go with that.
So that is what we thought we'll plan with.
So we will modify, you know, Zoho also accordingly and we will notify you there will be any email communication also that will come to you all around this.
Go ahead, but the.
So you did.
Does it mean that we will have a reduced sick leave options for individuals in the year?
No, no, no, no.
Actually we have 22 PTO's right in the year are leaving the holidays alone.
You have 22 PDO, K12 casual leaves and 10 privilege and Wellness leaves.
Uh.
OK, 12 earned leaves are earned leaves.
We call them as earned leaves.
Yeah.
So yeah, it it it's actually prorated base it gets added if I'm not wrong, yeah.
I mean, I'm don't know what the hell.
Yeah, I'm talking, talking about the whole year.
OK.
Like for the entire year, you have 12 and leave and 10 no privileged bar Wellness leave.
Last year it was mentioned that's privileged bar Wellness leave OK, which means the entire 22 days like we can choose whenever we want.
OK, it's up to us to choose when when we want to take that leave now we are kind of bringing it.
A slight modification to that where 18 days no employees can choose.
OK, we can choose whenever we want.
All those 18 days?
OK, four days will be.
You still have an option, but you have a a limited option where we define certain optional no Wellness holidays and that six days has four days has to be confined within that six Wellness, no optional holidays.
So that's going to be 2-2 days in Thanksgiving and another four days in towards the end of the year, between Christmas and New Year.
OK, so you can choose any four days within the 60 optional leaves, holidays, OK, rest 18 days.
It's up to the employees to choose.
We are not, you know, putting any limitations there or not putting any boundaries there.
It's really just from from most of the people who work on, at least in in in our projects, right.
I think we work all the all those weeks as well.
OK.
So I think having that kind of boundary making us to only fit there, right, I think leaving it as as today is helpful for teams like us.
So yeah, yeah, we know.
We know this high.
I expected this question, so you if you happen to work on those, if you kind of have to work on all those six days or if you were not able to, you know, avail no part or the entire four days leave, then you can claim a comp off.
OK, compound will be paid.
You can either choose to pay get paid for those days, or you can carry forward that as a comp off to the next year or whenever you want.
OK.
OK, if you happen to work on this.
Like.
And and not not only not only to this any, just just to add on Ashok's point, even I was like coming to that only because this fits very well if you're talking about widely Deloitte projects right, because we know those are the set down times, but if we consider non delight right, which is like major person right now maybe across data we see.
Umm.
So that's where we'll have to see because let's say if we give that option and let's say entire team goes on leave, I mean, we'll have to plan better.
That's that's the bottom line.
Thank you. Like.
Like we have to make sure in advance that you all don't go like let's say we talk about Annex Cloud or Vecna and all.
Let's say if everybody plans, because.
OK.
That is the four days I want to choose, then, then obviously product will be a problem.
So yes.
I mean, if people are kind of taking that as an informed believe, we cannot do much that say the whole purpose of that leave is Wellness.
OK, unless there is a crushing need.
So when we plan our deliveries, we need to plan deliveries in a way that we allow people to take those videos, OK.
And and if that did not happen, and if there is a due to some contingency if we were, if we have a she need to work on those days, then compound is the next option.
OK, so basically the idea is for people to take a break.
OK, so we need to plan our deliveries accordingly concerning those four or six days as optional holidays and you know move forward.
And customers also most US or any Western customer or even these days no Middle East and Singapore customers are also kind of concerned there is a quite period, OK.
So if you tell them that it's going to be a a quite period, our Wellness time, they will also agree to it.
OK.
Just that we need to plan our deliveries accordingly.
OK, my my only point was he maybe rather than just two, maybe our team can do more research like maybe for for APAC reason we know the Chinese New Year is the time where they all go on a leave.
So that kind of option we know for a Middle East, it's a either type which is that kind of period where like entire week or three or four is gonna have.
Umm.
So rather than just considering the Thanksgiving N and the Christmas, maybe we can think of like putting this kind of bucket like two more buckets for for maybe kind of reasons we support.
Yeah.
So that might maybe the more more balance but but yeah, I'm.
Chief, we will.
We will check that out to soon.
We'll check that out.
Yeah. Thanks.
But did you?
Sure, she don't.
You wanna speak on, OK?
Did metrics.
I'm sure so.
Thank you.
On hackathon, what do they want to?
Yeah, Hackathon is a major topic.
We have.
So W A-Team like we have come to a final stage out of 22 for resistance, 19 were able to successfully.
Don't know work with the team able to get their MVP going and towards the final lap of their work.
I think 14 of them were able to submit even we kind of a lot of give a grace time and encouragement and support from the outside so able to have 14 and let's as part of this code Jeannie Hackathon initiative.
So out of this 1418 demos evaluation demo have been completed, so as of today we are planning for remaining 6 to happen next week.
There were a lot of interesting use cases being dealt by our team.
I think once we have this concluded, they will present the data with you and solutions team as well as the are you know branding team can also make use of it.
They're planning for either outside or inside the, so all hands meeting we would like to felicitate the winners as well as talk some nice stories from this code.
Jeannie, with all of you over a town hall meeting.
So we will plan it ahead and then give you a heads up a week or two so that you also can participate and encourage their fellow Canadians who took their effort here.
And of course, we can appreciate the fellow organizers for towards this code GENNING.
And this time we have a very interesting and little higher number on from awards point of view.
So we'll have that announced and we are thinking to introduce not just the top three winners, probably you know best presenter best who followed the guidelines.
Lot of other categories are trying to introduce or to I'm of kind of ideate and then get the approval from the team and then we will circulate over a town hall meeting in a few weeks from now.
So that's one good traction.
I think we see a lot of new things been used and a lot of learnings have happened out of this thing.
Team have taken help from not just the contestants.
Also, the outside of their team, and like BSA QAS and architects, they kind of had a borrowed time from a learning point of view.
I think it's a good to see witness all those things happened on the floor.
That's a good update you like to Mom.
Ashar has Vijay mentioned one, another aspect is skill set matrix.
We'll be running a campaign.
It's a as you know, it's a continuous effort once in two or three months.
It's always better that our we encourage our team members to go back to their Zoho check on this skillset.
If they have upgraded their skill from one to other proficiency or acquired a new skill, or acquire a new certification, it's better to update in ZOHO.
As you know, most of us take rely on so for various inputs.
A right from aligning a person to a different project or upskilling them or skilling to a new role or whatnot like so.
It's really important, so please kind of urge your team to revisit their social profile once in two months is much, much recommended.
We will definitely run our campaigns.
Do our due diligence to follow up with them, but we need your help to, you know, including your skill sets as well as your team member skill sets.
Yeah, that's those are two major updates.
So we have here this point.
I'm good with.
She don't, vinit.
The final a date final final extended date for hackathon closure.
No.
A torture is I've done Sudha out of 14 finalists, 88 demos, the evaluation demos there them.
No, I'm sorry, the announcement of the final evaluations.
OK, so it should be in the week of 12th February or 19th February.
OK, fine.
So the yeah, yeah.
But OK, one point on this skillset matrix that Sriram was mentioning.
Ohh, let me, let me tell you where the pain point that we currently have.
When we started the skill set matrix, I think even 2-3 years back it was as part of onboarding we you are supposed to.
Everybody's supposed to update their skill sets and whenever they're upskilling our cross skilling we are encouraging them to go back and update it.
Now as part part of the bench, we have also come up with a Zoho bench module.
Most of you might be knowing it and maybe using it also as the recent example.
There were a couple of opportunities for mobile application developer.
Uh.
And GT meant two and sales team went to the bench.
We did not have any any mobile developers with Kotlin experience, Java and Kotlin experience right?
That was not updated in the skill set, so it was not reflecting in the bench.
But then when we discussed our, interacted with the resources, then we got to know that they got Kotlin, but by default we assumed that the skill set is not updated.
So we thought we don't have resources.
So we were actually going ahead and hiring in the market, right?
Also, there are a couple of, I mean not couple many of them.
They mentioned themselves as from back end developers, but then their skill sets are updated as front end developer so there's so much of discrepancies, so it's very important for the team for the RMG team, for the talent delivery team to deploy the people in the right projects.
The skills that has to be updated properly, that's #1 #2.
Whenever we are working on any proposals in RFPs, we normally project what the organization capabilities are right in terms of product, in terms of technology, in terms of domain, whatever, right?
So for that also we need some data points to understand how many people are agile certified, how many people are reacting E 0 or react to E3 developers right?
We want to know that so that we can project that as a good organization capability and that actually gives us many brownie points if we project it in that way and we are struggling a lot in order to come up with that.
But we know as an organization of, I mean 1000 member eight, 800 member organization, we have so many expertise, but we are not able to collect it as a report and project it.
So it's very important that we update our skill sets and every time whenever we are up, we are up skilling our graph killing.
Let's ensure we go ahead and update it and so.
Let's uh please make it as a as a practice to all your teams and cascade it.
And this is going to be taken for all their career growth, for their promotion recommendations for everything.
OK, for this is going to be a very important parameter going forward.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm good.
And so that just to thank you for the for adding that point, I'm, I'm just thinking one more leading aspect to cover here and also take your input.
So as you know, all of us know, like right now the skill set matrix is little exhaustive.
Obviously we can't restrict, but at the same time when it comes to sales pitch or organization capability, matrix pitch always, we won't rely on primary skills, right?
And then also good know the secondary skills.
So right now, since we don't have a direct capability in kind of message capability, the fields I'm talking about are the form.
So we wanna take a report from skill set matrix.
Whoever the the skills are tagged as three and four in terms of proficiency 3 and four are the maximum.
The higher end of it, so consider them as a primary, and then whichever is one and two can be of secondary.
So that's one smart way of leveraging the existing data at the same time.
Not too much, you know, take time to generate a report.
Of course, if there any changes to that, we can always do it.
But do you wanna take that approach so that we also in parallel build some primary and secondary skills data of our resources?
We're also gonna kickstart that effort very soon so that this means.
Again, we're gonna rely on skill set matrix data with people as long as they can keep that up to date along with certification standings completed.
It's a lot more helpful for us to take some meaningful and actionable data from that.
I'm good.
That she don't.
So the anything?
Yeah, I'm good.
Busy.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So one of The thing is we've been talking about this time sheets and all that right this last month also we had closed about 12 people until the payroll date.
They had not even filled one day of timesheet.
So you're like for you to kind of, we had to remind them all just before running payroll, we had to remind them.
So it gets a little difficult.
I hope each one of us or approving the you know, regularizations or the time sheets on time, at least on a weekly basis, that they kind of help us to consolidate a little better than pushing everything till the month end.
So that'll be a really, really great help, right?
So you want to get a little more organized there, so that will kind of help us across the org, right?
PMO team is also behind us to kind of ensure that this is something that really helps them right.
So any any challenges that you face there, both this time tracking and which is our attendance and timesheets or two standalone things, all of us are aware right because some of the employees also reached out saying that we thought there is a dependency and all that both are independent and we had been constantly sending reminders on that.
I hope all of us are in the same page there, right?
Camping Smitty silent.
OK, so this is something that I just want to reiterate here.
That's about it.
But now it's open to all of you.
All you have any questions, we can go ahead.
Yeah, I mean, we can manage this.
Can insist in the scrum call because when few people reach out to me, they say that they have been maybe like the emails are sending out to them which they miss out.
But even the managers and their one of the scrum call right and all of the meeting in the weekends.
I think they can insist on this.
It looks like that is not happening.
I didn't sending weekly reminders.
Also Shiva, it's there in the calendars.
Yeah, maybe you reminder.
Yeah, yeah, I I said that weekly money is being sent on top of it.
Maybe like managers can also like talk to them in one of this printer calls to them because like I think few of them are not seeing email even that is I'm not sure what to do with them.
Few, like, they're not seeing emails as well.
So maybe like managers, you know, one of their scrum calls, they can insist on this and think that is about right.
Definitely they will have this habit as problem.
Yeah.
The guys we should set a very, very strong disciplinary action against people who are not following this basic hygiene.
OK, this goes back to your delivery process also, right.
The customers also keeps complaining about this.
We are not following the basic hygiene.
That same thing is happening in our internal organization compliance as well, right?
If somebody is not able to fill timesheet even one day in spite of sending reminders, blocking your calendars and then PM was sending email, HR, sending emails and in spite of it is managers needs to talk in the scrum calls, you guys really need to set up right precedence there.
This is not at all acceptable, and then all of us, if forty of us are in this call, we are spending 10 minutes of our time talking about it, right?
This is totally unacceptable, guys.
Next month onwards, in fact, this month itself, we all, I mean Srini myself, we were discussing and HR had sent an email saying payroll has to be detected, but we just stopped that.
But if we are going to do this, then definitely I think there is no other point.
There is no other option for us.
We have to take some disciplinary action.
That's it.
Just let them know.
It is very, very basic discipline.
If we are not able to log our time on what we are doing, we are definitely doing something wrong.
Let's talk about contractors.
For them, they will get paid only if they lock the timesheets right.
They have to send the timesheet in order for them to get paid.
That's all we have to look at.
There are organizations who are even tracking when you are leaving out and when you are going in, right?
We are definitely not want that kind of a culture that is not to track people what they are doing, but it is basically for people to understand how productive they are, right.
And there are organizations who are going with productivity monitoring tools and few of you have suggested that also actually recommended that as well, right?
We are not going with those things.
All we want is a basic discipline for you to fill your attendance, to fill your timesheet.
That's it.
And if you want HR team to block your calendar, let's block your calendar for everything.
OK, like reminder for you to start from home for us to come to office for us to leave office, if that is what we wanted, let's do that as well.
Let's send a strong note to your teams, guys.
We can't spend time in talking about that, and it's not here.
Internally, we are spending a lot of time reviewing the triport and then seeing who have not done this and whether we should take action.
Maybe we understand that they are into deliveries, I mean schedules all that is OK, but not spending 5 minutes is not at all acceptable we.
Let's not even 5 minutes should it's even less.
Yeah.
It's like, no, they can do it from the mobile phone.
OK, all they need is over people app on their mobile phone and they just have to.
It will take not more than 40 seconds 45 seconds for them to do that.
Everything is preconfigured, they just have to go click and select.
That's all.
OK. Yeah.
Now it's as simple as that, yeah.
OK.
So any query.
And and yeah, there were challenges.
People mentioned here timesheet is not approved, attendance is not approved.
So timesheet we have we cannot fill actually PMO team needs that both dependency OK for them to track certain other things.
But just because this is a hindrance, they they removed the dependency because of removing that dependency.
Operationally, they have to spend more time, but they they agreed to do that.
That's again to help people.
OK, so we have to have that basically and we as an approver we have to approve that attendance very quickly, yeah.
Thanks, bye.
Any other points for discussion?
Yeah, if if no other topic, I think which which we had a call with the gay team.
Right.
Just just to want to bring their concerns.
Uh, I think definitely the K2022 is some someone.
I think it's I think that that call hope which you also felt their unhappiness or the start of dissatisfaction.
So just we we also had like there are almost everyone having a one to one and the exact same message was passed on to us as well.
And we also I think whatever the similar message which you you you told right, I think we also had the similar discussion but just I want to bring that as an concern from the whole team.
It's not like part like different one person or 2% right?
It's the whole team is unhappy, so it's just just want to bring it to.
I'm sure this is this will be definitely discussed in the past and going to be discussed, but just just want to bring everyone's notice here.
Or I think Ashok, we can take it offline long.
So then shrini, I think we don't have to spend everybody's time here, right?
Sure, sure.
Yeah.
We'll take it separately. Yep.
Sure.
Any other point or false?
I'll be good.
Looks like they're the most silent meeting that I have ever joined.
I mean, especially the Friday meeting this particular meeting.
Generally it won't be.
I'm not sure why silent down is.
I think they're very tired, so that.
All good otherwise.
Nor the points for discussion.
Yeah.
OK, Ashok, you want to just stay back?
Ashok, maybe we can speak to Sudan.
Srini.
Yep.
Sure.
OK, I will can drop off.
Thank you so much.
Or maybe we can join in another call, Ashok.
I just.
Thank you all.
We'll just, yeah.
Yeah.
It's kind of call Ashok on teams.
Sure.
Yeah, yeah.
All of you can call all of this.
Ashok, his dad in Chennai office.
Yeah.
I shoot.
OK.
Only Srini, I hope you are still insane.
Sure.
You can walk up to srini's desk if you wish.
Yeah.
Yeah, we can join from here.
It's OK if you want.
Sure, Joshua, sure.
So then I will call you shiny now.
Yeah, sure. OK.
4.
This is like a Tamil movie where hey everybody, you want to talk, come to this office or go to other office, right? So.
Something.
Well that.
Yeah.
Well, I think is in just quiet Chennai location, but he has not spoken to any of Chennai guys as often he still talking in phone and he's talking I across many times just say hi by the sound it's sort of the.
Hi do you want?
He will still be talking with this climate or location guys earlier over the phone though.
He's in Chennai.
Yeah, baby, it's every others.
Yeah, we sure.
You and I have not.
Yeah, I told you.
Right.
Vishwa I told you right.
Many of visited here but still they are like that.
It's an alcohol.
It's a dark hole.
No, no, you won't believe something.
We were in a dark hole.
Cool.
Now customer is gone.
Yeah.
Let's let's meet.
Maybe you are like many of visited here, but it looks like they were in four girls.
Are they are not talking to chat like this, they were just came here.
That's it.
No, she writes the other way.
I think the team already pinged in a group saying Ashok say hi.
At least that's the message I got from from.
That then it's more serious also because even we are looking for you and we are not able to find it out.
So whom you are talking now?
Hey.
And then no, no.
It's same thing pressure that you you can catch you only over teams chat not 10%.
If you comes in personal so you don't talk to you, OK?
No, no.
If you walked into the boardroom, you would.
In even in Coimbatore also, he will not say.
Then you guys really need to find out with whom he's talking.
Wait.
Uh, yeah, that, that.
So obviously, Coimbatore team says no Prashant saying no.
Then I don't know to whom he's talking so.
That is another thing we have to see is.
Even in Coimbatore also, he will not.
He will not, he will say only hi by that's all he will be always on calls, even in Coimbatore.
Hmm.
I think it's a bad nothing to start in this call today.
Open.
OK. Yeah.
He's here for a week.
It's better though I live.
I have not even spoken to you actually.
Correct, correct.
OK.
It's better that we write.
Ashok, you're always with your team.
Alright.
Not bothered about the others.
OK, sure.
Enough damage then, for Ashok today, so.
Yeah, yeah.
OK. Yeah.
Thank you all.
Have a happy.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
Weekend everyone.
Shook.
Thank you.
You everybody, thank you.
Bye bye.
Thank you team.
Thanks everybody.
Thank you all, bye.
Thank you. Bye.
Have a nice weekend everyone.
Have a great weekend. Bye.
Everyone have a happy weekend.
Goodbye.
Thank you.
Times 2.
You too.
Bye all.
Thank you.
Bye, right?
She, me, and Callie shrini.
Yeah.
Just give me a minute.
She.
Or you call me shrini.
I'm just generating the transcript.
I'm OK.
I like value as soon as I, Ashok comes here.
I'm yeah, sure. Sure, sure.
OK.
Sure.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Soon.
Then we can pass through the.
Bye. Yeah.
OK. Bye.
Yeah.
2nd generally doing the club.
Is clean.
Huh.
Even though he letting everybody on the DNR, I'm like screen share, I don't know what the camera and get it OK, showing my love on the meeting notes, but I'm sure.
Meet up another guy.
Don't be lazy.
Leave Policy modification Act Cortana updates kill set metrics time feeling comes.
New policing, $1,000,000 for the modification modified leave policy skill set matrix subject the best is not employees.
Pretty we get.
I mean, I was and then I'll have my miss.
OK, wait, is doing things.
Compile it.
And when modelling little action items and clearer action items love me on the like, I think no call start, only enable my and on a learning and my apologies, call control, OK, call start point of building a way to cope with letting go to mute on that other part of the banana.
The formula More promptly appointed if in the meeting is in which you know what questions are unresolved, or deeming port or not.
And they are summarized for so long.
OK, so now in the problem meeting your transcript, the best for me now about the summarize for me go to the.
But then the question vision, another call, all this for different regions, we support OK suggestions and I'm sure they'll take their.
There was no follow up on out there.
When they do the possibilities and with the survey want employees to fill out the preferred option.
All this and then communicate themselves because you know.
Somewhere over there.